colorado might become the second state
to legalize
human composting and to allow human
remains to be composted after a person
passes away
love you grandma love you grandpa hey i
love you great aunt becky
can't wait to put you in my garden can't
wait to eat tomatoes that sprout out of
your liver or something no
gross that's bad there was an article in
the washington exam
which i i had to read because i think it
shows you
the divergence between the old
right-wing order and the new right-wing
order
this one i think is representative of
the old
kind of squishy wing of the right over
the past 20 years
the writer says headline he won't allow
over-the-counter birth control
but biden is pushing risky at home
abortions
so to me when i read that headline i say
okay
so biden's baton 500 here you know that
allowing risky at home abortion is bad
but hey at least he won't allow
over-the-counter birth control but then
i find in the article
the author writes quote an easy solution
here would be to deregulate oral
contraceptives so that uninsured women
can acquire them over the counter
reducing the pills list price over time
and reducing unplanned pregnancies among
a democratic
demographic least able to afford
children lucky for biden senate
republicans such as joni ernst of ohio
of iowa rather
among others are on board with this this
that's that's the opposite
of what we ought to do that is exactly
the wrong
conclusion why
why michael because you're a scold a
prude a theocrat
no why would we make it easier
even than it already is it's extremely
easy to access oral contraceptives why
would we make it easier
so that underage girls can get them that
would be one
that would be one consequence of
over-the-counter
oral contraceptives so that we can
further reduce our birth rate we already
have a dying population we already have
a very low birth weight
should we really do that so that we can
further
promote the hookup culture and the
culture of casual sex that has given
rise to the metoo movement and
claims of epidemic sexual assault on
campus around the country
because of that because it makes women
so much happier
because it makes families so much more
stable no
i don't it doesn't make any sense at all
i'm making a prudential judgment here
based on the actual circumstances
of the country i'm not making some
totally abstract rational argument
rationalist argument rather whereby the
only the only principle in our politics
is maximizing individual autonomy
and individual liberty meaning our
basest passions
i'm just looking at the prudence of it
why would we do that that seems like it
would be worse
right sometimes to have greater freedom
you have to say no
there is this common thread have you
noticed this to liberal activism to
left-wing activism even
among the sort of libertarian or squishy
types on the right
they always seem to want fewer people
notice that they want legal abortion
in the name of women's rights they want
subsidized contraception
or much even easier access than we
already have to contraception in the
name of personal autonomy
they want euthanasia in the name of
mercy they want
smaller families because of climate
change or overpopulation
completely made up problem they want to
pump
little kids full of hormones that will
castrate them in the name of
transgender health so no matter what
what the argument
they always seem to want fewer people
isn't that weird
does that make you think huh what is the
what is the metaphysical aspect going on
what is that what is the
dare i say it spiritual
underpinning of all these policies that
seem to be so
anti-human we've got one of the more
ridiculous examples right now in
colorado
colorado might become the second state
to legalize
human composting and to allow human
remains to be composted after a person
passes away
love you grandma love you grandpa hey
love you great aunt becky
can't wait to put you in my garden can't
wait to eat tomatoes that sprout out of
your liver or something no
gross that's bad and why is it bad why
is it bad
i understand the rationalist argument
for composting grama
okay the rationalist argument is look
come on it's just you're just taking a
dirt nap
just turn into worm food anyway might as
well get some
heads of lettuce out of you why come on
we're all just stuff we're all just
matter right we're all gonna turn to
dust anyway right even
we are from dust we are and to dust we
shall return so why not just toss
someone in the backyard let the
let the wolves come and eat you or let
some
let some vegetables grow out of you
there is a natural revulsion that we
have at this
it's what the bioethicist leon cass
would call the wisdom of repugnance
it seems anti-human seems pretty
undignified this is
human dignity according to the libs is
turning your grandma into mulch
let me ask you something if you're if
you're tempted to go along with the
colorado thing
if you were walking along the street and
you saw a dead body
would you kick it would you spit on it
would you desecrate that body
no i bet you wouldn't if you god forbid
stumbled on
a member of your family dead you some
this has maybe happened to a number of
people
would you attack that by would you punch
it
would you desecrate that body no you
wouldn't you just wouldn't do it
why not the rationalist in you would say
that's just a hunk of flesh
well the word desecrate tells you
everything because you recognize that
there is
something sort of sacred about
the human person there is some hint of
divinity there
that man is made in the image of god
that we treat
even a dead body with certain special
care that's why it's against the law to
desperate bodies
why is that because we recognize at
least on some gut level we used to
recognize in our whole culture
that we're not just meat puppets we're
not just worm food we're not just
flesh we are not just our fleshy desires
our will is not just our fleshy desires
we have spirit and soul too and we have
a higher
rational faculty and a higher rational
will
too and we need to treat humans as a
little bit more special
and we need to treat human society as
more than just
our appetites and our desires in the
economically
rational materialist self-interested
society we're more than that culture is
more than that
conservatism is more than just saving a
couple bucks
and letting people pursue whatever
disorder desires they have
well what is it what's more than that i
think it's pretty clear
that our traditions our rituals our
american way of life
our self-respect our dignity is what
we're aiming at here
and the conservatives who recognize that
are giving us an opportunity for a
future
here a future for conservatives and a
future for the country
and the ones who don't recognize that
are only
driving faster or slower off the cliff
on the way to decline
hey smash that like button subscribe
hit the bell so that you do not miss any
content from the michael knowles show
you